علقت همم يعني عدد من القيادات السياسيه
في البلاد وعلى راسها الرئيس
فلاديميرسيلياسيسكي وكذلك القياده
العسكريه وعلى راسها وزير الدفاع الجنسيه
رزين كوف والقائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
فاليري زولوجي اتفق القاده على ان عمليه
الانسحاب من قبل الاتحاد الروسي من منطقه
خرسون هي همم ليست همم ابداع حسني نيه من
قبل الاتحاد الروسي وليس لانها الاتحاد
الروسي يرغب في ذلك وان هذا وانما هذا
نتيجه للضغط الكبير من قبل القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه في هجومها المضاد على منطقه
خرسانه واستعاده عدد كبير من همم
في مقاطعه خرسون طبعا هنا ايضا لابد ان
نذكر كما تتحدث
وقال ان هناك عمليه تمت من قبل القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه خلف خطوط القوات
الروسيه تم قطع الطرق الاستراتيجيه
للامداد تم تدمير الجذور التي يمكن من
خلالها انت تيم عمليه الانسحاب لذلك الان
اصبح هنالك طرق ضيقه جدا ولا يوجد وقت
للقوات الروسيه ان لم تنسحب في الوقت
الحالي هذا سيجعل القوات الروسيه في قبضه
القوات الاوكرانيه وهذه السياسه متبعه
احمد طبعا في عمليه الهجوم المضاد من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه اتبعتها في خاركه في
اتبعتها في الايمان وهي تقوم بعمليه
القوات الروسيه ولكن تترك لها مجال
للانسحاب ذلك لحفظ للحفاظ على المواطنين
في تلك المدن وكذلك للحفاظ على البنيه
التحتيه للمدينه وعلى المدن التي سيكون
طبعا من الصعب طبعا عمليه الاستعاده لها
ايضا
ومع اعلان ايضا حذيفه ال ال القوات
الاوكرانيه انها سيطره على عد من المدن
والبلدات حول خيرصون هل هناك خطط واضحه من
الحكومه الاوكرانيه ومعلنه لاعاده
النازحين الى مناطقم
في الحقيقه
في البدايه تبدا عمليه تمشيط من قبل
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه من قبل المشاه
ثم بعد ذلك تبدا الفرق المتخصصه في عمليه
ازاله العلاقات والبحث والبحث عن
المتفجرات ثم بعد ذلك تبدا عمليه استعاده
البنيه التحتيه خطوط الكهرباء والمياه
والغاز والتدفئه في المدينه بعد ذلك يفتح
الطريق ويفتح المجال
للعوده الى الاستقرار في هذه المدن هذه
الخطه المتبعه في جميع المناطق التي تم
استعاده السيطره عليها وكذلك هذا يحدث في
منطقه خرسانه
عن انباء تتحدث عن همم سيطره الجيش
الاوكراني على او استعاده الحدود الاداريه
الكامله لمنطقه همم علم التاكيدات لهذه
الانباء
نعم هذا صحيح طبعا مدينه سنيوريفكا هي اخر
المدن التي كان يسيطر عليها الجيش الروسي
في الحدود الاداريه لمقاطعه نيكا لايف وهي
تقع على الحدود الاداريه ما بين نيكا لايف
وما بين اخر سون هذه المدينه مدينه هامه
جدا هي معقل كانت للقوات الروسيه في
الجنوب هذه المدينه سيطر عليها الرسل
ثمانيه اشهر لذلك استعاده هذه المدينه كان
هامه جدا بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه يعني
الامر صحيح ان كامل الان المقاطعه اصبحت
في قبضه القوات الاوكراني هذا بالاضافه
طبعا الى لابد ان اضيفنا انه كان هنالك
هجوم صاروخي على مدينه قتل خمسه اشخاص وتم
انقاذ طفل في السادسه عشر عمره وما زال
عمان لقاء حتى هذه اللحظه يعملون همم يعني
للبحث عن اي مصابين او اي حاجه